before we cover the speech some more
let's take a test in terms of success
who would you rather be this or this
it's good to start with perspective
given that most polls show widespread
approval upwards of 75 percent for Trump
speech still the loyal opposition
couldn't let go of their emotionally
clouded by as long as Trump mentioned
good news they frowned one clown even
bolted when a patriotic chant broke out
and they speak of division they stat
they sat when they should have stood
even for the flag you think Americans
didn't notice that Trump placed that
moment right in our faces the Dems are
confused Trump's hitting all the high
notes and they don't know what to do
they're officially Dean wormer from
Animal House always scowling at good
news Schumer looked like he didn't know
whether to wind his watch or cry Pelosi
looks like she discovered her chauffeur
it just broken wind and when Trump
called out socialism half the Dems
looked nervously toward the exits
someone should have checked on Bernie
Sanders did he expire from too much
common sense if the old saying is true
that progressivism is the fear that
someone somewhere is making America look
good then this was a really bad night
for progressives so why the media
couldn't handle it either
immigration is one opportunity to have a
big success quickly but I have to tell
you I think his rhetoric last night set
things back did not advance the ball
forward calling this a healing speech is
almost like calling going on a diet by
drinking a diet coke and eating a pizza
that's as much of a healing speech this
way you tell me like this to the great
dictator that was like her when he was
running so Trump set a trap for the Dems
in the media that exposed their biases
but hey everyone has a role to play and
in team sport politics someone's got to
be the loser Pelosi Schumer the hapless
media they do it all so well
all right jesse is what do you make of
it do you think that Democrats should
have been more gracious or is this to be
expected I remember there were people
that were like this with Obama I mean
there are people that shouted at Obama
during one a specific event that I can't
remember you lie yes you like Joe Wilson
yeah yeah yeah I just think the
Democrats look like the media out of
touch with the American people if you
have snap polls saying that they thought
it was unifying oblivia and he deserves
more credit for the good success of
America and then the media is saying
it's gloomy it's dark it's poisonous
there's a huge disconnect so you had
Frank Luntz and zombie to Big Time
pollsters both say home run and if he
canyon continues to perform like this
the Republican Party may save the house
in the Senate and he's gonna even win
re-election but not only did they not
clap at some of those moments he just
brought up about the rising wages and
more jobs they didn't clap when there
was talk about a pathway to citizenship
lowering drug prices they didn't clap
about destroying Isis they didn't clap
about the recovery of Steve Scalise one
of their own colleagues think about so
it's almost like you kind of what I saw
not what I saw check the tape but you
can still applaud the success of America
but you don't have to agree with
everything Trump says it's almost like
they care more about their party than
they do about the country
imagine if the Democrats didn't clap
when we won gold medal in the Olympics
because Trump was president that's kind
of the disconnect
but the president's done something very
skillful here he's so closely associated
himself with the flag with the country
and the economic success when the
Democrats root against him they look
like they're rooting against America but
he's also triangulated when it comes to
manufacturing infrastructure and trade
that helps American workers so the
Democrats are in a tough position where
they're boxed in are they going to
choose what's good for their own base
are they gonna follow Nancy and crying
Chuck and that's the question going into
the midterm that's actually I didn't
even consider that Dana what point Jesse
said said he's aligned himself with
patriotic symbols
so that if you are against him you're
kind of against the flag it way it's
almost a parallel that if you were
against President Obama you're racist so
it's kind of like you align yourself
with certain kinds of I in this case
identity politics in this case
unification patriotism yeah I was
thinking when they didn't stand for when
the Democrats didn't stand well not I
should say didn't I had a Democrat on my
show today who did stand for rising
wages so I'll take it back and they they
are lacking a message though and they
don't have the bully pulpit and they
know that in their in their districts
all of these citizens are seeing good
headlines about the economy
so there is a disconnect so for people
who watch the speech most of those tend
to be people who like the president
anyway they're like they're going
forward and the Democrats are starting
to lose ground in the Congressional
ballot Republicans have made
considerable ground in even in just a
month I think what the Democrats could
have done from a communication
standpoint is just stood up and cheered
and applauded it and give it a
high-fives to each other saying we did
this for you congrat we are we are happy
to have helped you President Trump to
inherit this great economy and we are
absolutely going for going to go forward
to try to win back the working class and
also take credit for some of these
centrist and democratic ideas that he
floated like paid family leave yeah I
mean yeah there's some liberal stuff
going in there Kimberly what are your
thoughts yeah I think though that the
dinner brings up a great point which is
there was plenty there for them to say
hey listen we were contributory to this
we helped we're trying to get the
country to prosper as relates to the
economy as well in tax reform etc but
instead they chose to be partisan and
not to be honest in terms of okay this
is what's happened this is what we feel
we've tried to contribute this is what
is in fact good for the country they did
not want to even begrudgingly give kind
of any credit or acknowledge any
participation because to give him any
credit for honest-to-god achievements
with too much for them to swallow one
your batting cleanup here why does your
side look like a bunch of sore losers
you get 10 seconds let me just say I am
so curious and listening because for
with the young man huh and the flags at
the graves right right how can you guys
not see that he's going after people who
say I'm having a legitimate protest
about police brutality by refusing to
stand at the national anthem that's a
choice that people are making but what
Trump has done is he has now demonized
anybody who doesn't stand with this
little boy who's bringing flags to a
grave how can you not do it forget that
you can't do it because you're so upset
and you want America to know that
there's police brutality in the world
right then similarly let me just say
with regard to wages yes how can you not
say Oh Trump says wages are up under me
guess what wages have been rising since
2014 you're doing a block I'm just
telling you that there is so much here
that Trump steers and distorts and twist
and you guys say oh he's patriotic
everything is great I just think it's
you know all right but I just wanted we
gotta surrender that I get a move on you
compared to two ideas okay so in Trump's
case he asked this young boy on to talk
about this amazing thing he's doing that
is a well articulated principle that
he's exposing he's showing this the
dealing stuff was poorly articulated
nobody really knew what it meant it had
to be people had to keep repeating it
over and over again and it became a
question of patriotism not a question of
brutality if they had done something
towards the they'd gone to their police
department and protested there that
would make sense that's why you're
comparing a well articulated vision with
one that was convoluted and they're
wrapping it wasn't careful you forget
Colin Kaepernick was very plain in
saying why he was doing it didn't work I
don't know if you think it worked or not
but I'm gonna tell you a lot of people
are sensitive to the argument he was on
the cover to leave yeah and a lot of
people are more sensitive and more we're
now because of black lives matter in
Colin Kaplan's defending Democrats not
standing for the flag let them for the
flag so Jesse pointed out to me on the
sheet it says that Democrats did not
stand for Steve Scalise I thought that I
saw that I saw they might have applauded
they didn't stand but this is where we
are in America yeah this is Green it's
where you wear your posture